so meine Damen und Herren mir der
Ehrgeiz hat mich gepackt nachdem wir
heute morgen 20 Minuten wieder gut
gemacht haben jetzt absolut in der Zeit
zu bleiben toll dass sie alle wieder da
sind sich einen Kaffee hoffentlich
getrunken haben jetzt haben wir hier
eine großartige großartiges Gespräch vor
uns aus ja was ein Einblick gibt in
unseren Podcast für Deutschland von
Andreas krobock gleich moderiert der
auch der zuständige für unseren Podcast
ist der ja ein sehr erfolgreiches
Produkt ist mit täglich um die 50.000
Hörerinnen und Hörer neben unserem
Podcast Festival haben wir den Podcast
also auch hier auf der Bühne und er hat
einen Gast über den ich nicht auch ganz
besonders Feuerwerk zu ihm habe ich
tatsächlich eine persönliche
vielleicht etwas weit gesagt persönliche
Beziehung klingt jetzt schief nein ich
meine ja ich war seine Studentin im
ersten Semester an der Universität zu
Köln ich habe kurz in die Politologie
reingeschnuppert und war bei Carlo
Masala der wir haben heute sagte häufig
zu Unrecht Masala Masala oder ähnlich
ausgesprochen sollte sondern für alle
die jetzt hier sind die haben dieses
Geheimwissen dass ich jetzt auch habe
Masala
das ist schön ich freue mich sehr dass
Sie hier sind erst jetzt Professor an
der bundeswehr-hochschule ständig in
Talkshows Experte für
militärfragen alles rund um den Ukraine
kriegsstrategische Fragen taktische
Fragen und darum geht es jetzt auch auf
diesem Panel der beiden Herren nämlich
um alles rund um den Ukraine krieg ich
freue mich sehr Sie und euch hier auf
der Bühne begrüßen zu dürfen nächsten 45
Minuten gehören euch
genau wie geplant jeder von einer Seite
wunderbar
voll schön dass Sie alle da sind
ich will ein paar Worte ganz kurz vorweg
sagen bevor wir gleich direkt loslegen
weil wir ja auch ein Podcast aufnehmen
der wird morgen
gesendet morgen gegen 17 Uhr also der
FAZ Podcast für Deutschland Helene
Borowski hat gesagt das machen wir
inzwischen seit drei Jahren und es macht
riesigen Spaß in diesem Haus Erz diese
podcast-familie gerade aufzubauen und so
werden wir diese Sendung jetzt auch
gleich quasi neben dem Livestream und
ihnen dir dankenswerterweise alle
erschienen sind wenn wir die Sendung
auch morgen bei uns ab 17 Uhr ungefähr
auf hat es nicht finden Sie das auf
Apple Spotify überall wo wir vertreten
sind gerade mal sein ist ja auch Podcast
da kennt es auch
aber vielleicht auch noch ein Wort zu
verlieren so genau also ich mache jetzt
quasi gleich die Begrüßung so als wird
die Sendung losgehen und wenn ich Carlo
Masala vorstelle und sie noch mal einen
warmen Applaus geben wenn das sehr
nett
noch nicht noch nicht
[Applaus]
so es ist sehr warm hier ziemlich warm
ne aber die Tür aufzumachen geht
wahrscheinlich aus Sicherheitsgründen
nicht bin gleich der Kanzler kommt
okay also ein Jahr
ein Monat eine Woche Krieg in Europa
kann ich der Jahrestag diese Zahlenreihe
aber doch eindrücklich ehrlich gesagt
bräuchten wir gar keine Zahlenreihe um
genug Gründe zu haben über diese neue
Welt in der wir leben und wie sie noch
sich verändern wird heute zu sprechen
herzlich willkommen also hier beim FAZ
Kongress liebes Publikum im Saal liebe
Zuschauer im Livestream weiß nicht wo
der genau ist und natürlich liebe
Hörerinnen und Hörer unseres Podcasts
für Deutschland unser Gast ist heute
jemand den sie alle in den vergangenen
ja ich würde sagen vor allem 13 Monaten
kennengelernt haben kennengelernt ist
vielleicht ein bisschen der falsche
Ausdruck das schaffen wir vielleicht
heute noch ein bisschen mehr aber seinen
Namen und seine Erklärungen zu diesem
Krieg in der Ukraine sind glaube ich
allen hier sehr präsent viele von ihnen
habe ich schon gehört sind auch seine
wegen gekommen vielen Dank dafür
und haben aber auch deine Einschätzung
mir muss ich sagen immer wieder
sehr geholfen die Situation auch aus der
Entfernung bisschen ein zu schätzen also
ich freue mich sehr dass du heute bei
uns bist ich sag's vorweg wir duzen uns
wir kennen uns schon eine Weile also
herzlich willkommen Caro Masala
vielen Dank für die Einladung dein
Applaus was macht das mit einem was
macht das mit dir seit über einem Jahr
den deutschen den Krieg zu erklären
was macht das mit mir es ist bringt mich
natürlich in eine Rolle rein die ich so
bislang nicht hatte also ich sag mal so
ich war die letzten 15 20 Jahre schon
immer medial präsent aber das sind halt
immer so Ereignisse die weiß ich nicht
mein Tag dauern mal vier Tage dauern ich
sag mal hast ja Abzug aus Afghanistan
war und Kabul Airport die
evakuierungsmission weil man das im
Sommer 2019 nee 2020
da war ich halt irgendwie vier Tage
präsent und dann ist das Event vorbei
und dann verlinke ich wieder versinki
ich wieder in meinem Büro und in meiner
Universität
und ich habe in der Tat naiv wie ich bin
gedacht am Anfang des Krieges na ja gut
das dauert jetzt so zwei drei Monate und
danach sucht man sich neue Gesichter
habe nicht erwartet dass das halt jetzt
seit 13 Monaten so geht
es macht viel mit allen also vor allen
Dingen das was passiert wenn man
im Fernsehen ist das was ein Reaktionen
kommt das macht schon viel mit einem
also dieser Krieg polarisiert ja auch in
einem Maße
dass wenn ich keine Ahnung ich bin in
irgendeiner Talkshow die wird um 22 Uhr
ausgestrahlt die geht bis 23 Uhr und
dann setzen sich jede Menge Menschen um
2 Uhr nachts an Ihren PC oder an Ihren
Laptop und Schreiben Hassmails also wenn
ich dann morgens um 5 Uhr aufstehe dann
habe ich irgendwie 40 Hass Mails ja nach
jeder Sendung 40 ungefähr 40 ist jetzt
so der Median also es ist teilweise es
gab teilweise Tage da waren sogar noch
mehr so und da muss man dickes Fell
haben und dadurch zu gehen hast du ja
ich habe einen extrem dickes Fell also
manchmal gibt so Situationen wo ich mir
manchmal denke oh Gott warum macht man
das ganze eigentlich aber in der Regel
habe ich einen extrem dickes Fell und
man kann mir sehr sehr wenig hättest du
vor dem 24 Februar vergangenen Jahres
überhaupt gedacht dass wir Deutschen uns
mal Krieg erklären lassen wollen
also ich bin ja mal da ich bin ja schon
lange davon ausgegangen dass dieser
Krieg stattfinden wird
ich habe nicht erwartet dass das
Interesse an Erklärung das Interesse
sozusagen an wirklich
fragen von Waffensystem Fragen von
Operationsführung so intensiv und so
groß sein würde wie es dann letzten
Endes geworden ist das habe ich nicht
erwartet also ich bin ja immer selber
jemand der seit irgendwie 30 Jahren
fordert dass wir Deutschen uns stärker
gesellschaftlich für sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik interessieren
müssen dass wir diese Debatte führen
müssen nicht werfe Berlin früher Bonn
heute Berlin immer vor dass sie diese
Debatte sozusagen nicht führen mit der
Bevölkerung
mich hat es trotzdem überrascht
wie intensiv diese Debatte teilweise
geführt wurde es ist auch toll der
Zeitenwende vielleicht das ist
sicherlich Teil der zeitenwände ja also
die Rückkehr ich sag mal die Rückkehr
eines
zwischenstaatlichen Krieges die Rückkehr
eines Angriffskrieges in Europa hat dazu
geführt dass ich die Deutschen wieder
für ja sehr militärische Fragen
interessieren das ist Teil der
zeitenwände natürlich klar magst du
eigentlich den Begriff Militärexperte
nee den mag ich überhaupt nicht den
gibt's ja auch nicht also ich bin
sozusagen jemand ich bin Professor für
internationale Politik und mein mein
Schwerpunkt ist sicher zum
Verteidigungspolitik von daher diesen
Begriff Militärexperte den gibt's
überhaupt nicht der ist mir irgendwann
mal reingepappt worden und dagegen zu
kämpfen ist natürlich gegen Windmühlen
zu kämpfen also ich laufe jetzt nicht
überall hin und sage stellen Sie mich
bitte nicht als militär-experten vor das
ist dann so ein Teil dessen ja ein
kundenker lässt macht wenn ihr wollt
aber ich bin halt jemand der sich auf
Sicherheit zum Verteidigungspolitik
spezialisiert aber das wäre immer als
Untertitel ein bisschen lang also könnte
es um
sagen wie würdest du am liebsten genannt
werden
internationale Politik
lass uns doch mal wenn wir heute ein
bisschen Zeit haben auch mal über deinen
Werdegang kurz sprechen wie du überhaupt
hingekommen bist also nicht nur heute
bei uns auf die Bühne sondern die wird
man denn einer der kriegsdeuter in
Deutschland was muss man dafür studiert
haben wie ist dieser Weg warst du selber
auch beim Militär
also ich bin ja italienischer
Staatsbürger gewesen deswegen hatte mich
die Frage Bundeswehr ja nicht tangiert
so ich bin ja erst mit 30 deutscher
Staatsbürger geworden
du musst es damals glaube ich um
professionell nicht um Professor werden
zu können um Akademischer Rat also eine
beamtete lebenszeitstellung an der
Universität zu Köln zu bekommen da muss
ich Deutscher werden weil damals die
Bundesrepublik es nicht geschafft hat EU
reicht in nationales Recht zu übertragen
und einen Monat nachdem ich dann
sozusagen diese Stelle bekommen hatte
und einen deutschen Pass hatte hat es
der Deutsche Bundestag geschafft
eu-rechte nationales Recht zu übertragen
wie wird man das ich habe eine
klassische Ausbildung ich habe
Politikwissenschaften studiert ich habe
irgendwann mal mich dann auf
internationale Politik fokussiert jetzt
muss man dazu sagen die Art und Weise
wie ich ausgebildet wurde theoretisch
ausgebildet wurde in der
Politikwissenschaft hat immer schon
einen großen Schwerpunkt auf die Frage
militärischer Macht und das Einfluss des
militärischer Macht auf internationale
Beziehungen gelegt also lag es irgendwie
nah dass ich mich auf diese
sicherheitspolitischen Fragen dann in
der Forschung konzentriert habe das
waren Teil meiner Doktorarbeit das war
dann aber der Schwerpunkt meiner
Habilitation
ich bin dann für vier Jahre zur NATO
gegangen und habe in Rom einen
Forschungsinstitut für die NATO mit
aufgebaut das beim military Community
verordnet war also der in dem
militärischen Armen der NATO und
sozusagen für den militärischen Arm der
NATO gearbeitet hat da habe ich die
theoretischen Kenntnisse und sozusagen
die beratungskenntnisse die ich vorher
schon hatte noch mal vertiefen können
der Gestalt dass ich gelernt habe wie
internationale Organisationen und auch
nationale Bürokratien zu
Entscheidungsprozessen kommen das hat
mir sehr geholfen bei dem was ich heute
mache und bin dann von oben aus
sozusagen an die Universität der
Bundeswehr berufen worden ja und da bin
ich seit 2007 und mache halt sicher zum
Verteidigungspolitik ob das jetzt der
klassische Weg ist wie man danach im
Fernsehen landet weiß ich nicht aber bei
mir hat es funktioniert
man kann also über Krieg reden ohne im
Krieg gewesen zu sein ja ich finde
sozusagen das ist es ist immer diese
komplett irrsinnige Vorstellung und die
kommt ja eigentlich nur von denjenigen
ähm die ein grundsätzliches Problem
damit haben dass man in dieser Situation
sozusagen nicht auf Seiten der
Russischen Föderation steht die diese
Frage stellen haben Sie denn gedient
jetzt muss man mal ganz einfach
folgendes sagen dass das sind ja ganz
ganz oft sind das Männer in meinem Alter
oder noch älter die haben gedient dann
irgendwann mal zwischen den 70ern und
80er Jahren das haben die gemacht die
waren 15 Monate bei der Bundeswehr am
Schießen gelernt und sind ein bisschen
im Schlamm geraubt woher sollen die
irgendeine Kenntnis über taktisch
operative Fragen haben das haben die 0
da wo du herkommst in Köln Chorweiler
mehr schon na ja zumindestens kann ich
mal sagen ich habe sicherlich öfters
geschossen weil einer meiner Onkels ist
ein Jäger mit dem war ich ganz ganz oft
zur Jagd und habe ohne den besitz eines
Waffenscheins dann schon den jungen
Jahren eine Waffe in die Hand gedrückt
bekommen um zu schießen weiß gar nicht
ob das heute hier verraten solltest der
Punkt ist sozusagen das ist der
österreichische Teil meiner Familie
deswegen ist das relativ egal
und deswegen ist diese Vorstellung
also wenn ich natürlich
in der deutschen Bundeswehr ein
Berufssoldat bin der die
Führungsakademie durchlaufen hat also
sozusagen diesen zweijährigen Lehrgang
wo man vorbereitet wird um höhere
Positionen in der deutschen Bundeswehr
inne zu haben dann sind das natürlich
Leute die sich extrem gut auskennen
diesen taktisch operativen Fragen aber
alle anderen haben null Ahnung davon
werfen aber einem vor oder die erste
Frage ist haben sie immer gedient man
kann das Studieren ich meine in den USA
in Großbritannien teilweise auch in
Frankreich sind das sozusagen
eigenständige unterdisziplinen in den
internationalen Beziehungen in denen man
sich mit solchen Fragen beschäftigt das
ist in Deutschland niederfall gewesen
weil wir sozusagen nach 45 die
internationalen Beziehungen sehr stark
in Richtung international Organisationen
Konfliktforschung und so weiter
schwerpunktmäßig hatten aber dieses was
man in den USA Security studies oder
sogar strateg also strategische Studien
nennt das ist ein ganz etabliertes Fach
und von daher kann man diese Sachen
analysieren man kann sie lernen und man
kann sie dann bewerten ich frage das
auch weil hier bei uns am Dienstag im
FAZ Podcast für Deutschland der
österreichische ich sag jetzt mal
Sicherheitsexperte fand Stefan Gady da
war und gesagt hat er sei tatsächlich
nach bachmut gefahren der war da jetzt
vor drei Wochen für eine ganze Woche
glaube ein Kilometer entfernt von der
Frontlinie Granaten sind um ihn
eingeschlagen wäre das für dich denkbar
oder macht es gar keinen Sinn
das wäre natürlich für mich denkbar und
es wäre sozusagen nicht das erste
Kriegsgebiet in das ich fahren würde
also in meiner nato-zeit ich war in
Afghanistan ich war im Irak ich war ganz
früher in Somalia also überall Gebiete
wo Krieg geführt worden ist jetzt muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen es kommt immer
auf die Fragestellung an die mich
interessiert ob das Sinn macht oder
nicht Sinn macht
ich fahre nicht in die Ukraine und das
hat ein ganz ganz einfachen Grund weil
ich es sozusagen überflüssig finde dass
ich dort Menschen binde die wichtigere
Aufgaben zu tun haben so ich finde auch
dass man größerer Punkt das so ein
großer Teil dieses polit-tourismus in
der Ukraine überflüssig ist ich finde
man soll
[Applaus]
ich finde wer in die Ukraine fährt soll
gefälligst was mitbringen ob es Geld ist
oder Panzer sind ist mir dann egal aber
er soll gefälligst was mitbringen und
nur in die Ukraine zu fahren damit ich
mal da war und gute Bilder mit den
Klitschkos oder mit selensky oder mit
wem auch immer habe
das ist aber da bin ich vielleicht
sozusagen ethisch moralisch auf einer
anderen Seite das finde ich er Touch so
und jetzt ich hatte zwei Einladungen die
Ukraine ich habe sie beide abgelehnt es
kann sein dass ich im September fahren
werde aber
noch mal ich bin wie holst du dir denn
die Infos dann sozusagen also wenn wenn
wir miteinander in der Sendung sprechen
wenn ich Interviews mit dir lese habe
ich das Gefühl du bist so dermaßen Dieb
informiert vielleicht auch für unser
Publikum wo holst du dir morgens deine
Informationen her womit fütterst du
deinen
verschiedene Quellen es gibt es gibt
natürlich Zeitungen
ich habe nicht gesagt welche hören Sie
auf zu lachen
es gibt sehr sehr gute Ohren sind
Accounts also Open Source intelligence
Accounts es gibt natürlich die
Verlautbarungen sowohl der Russischen
Föderation als auch der der Ukrainer
ich telefoniere sehr viel mit Leuten die
die in sozusagen diesen Situationen sind
und sie bewerten müssen das heißt jedes
Mal wenn ich das Gefühl habe ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob das was ich da sehe
richtig ist oder auch meine Einschätzung
richtig ist habe ich Leute mit denen ich
das Zurückspielen kann also Profis mit
denen ich das Zurückspielen kann und
fragen kann ob meine Einschätzung
richtig ist oder nicht richtig ist so
also von daher man kommt an viele Sachen
sehr gut an es gibt natürlich auch und
da sage ich jetzt mal
ich schätze Kollegen da die unglaublich
aber auch er wird bestimmte Fragen die
wir zum Beispiel rund um Bach Mut haben
nicht beantworten können weil die
Ukrainer da wirklich den Deckel drauf
halten ja und jetzt werden sie ihm auch
nicht verraten es gibt halt bestimmte
schwarze Flecken die kann man von außen
nicht beurteilen die weiß halt nur der
ukrainische Generalstab oder vielleicht
der russische Generalstab das sind für
uns schwarze Flecken die muss man dann
aber auch wenn man gefragt wird genau
als solche benennen
und jetzt ist es ja eigentlich auch so
dass diese reine Kriegstaktik und
Beobachtung dessen was da passiert gar
nicht mal dann allererstes Spezialgebiet
ist sondern es ist eigentlich sogar eher
die
Friedensforschung nein oder nein nein
internationalen Beziehung Frieden nein
kein Friedensforscher aber du machst dir
schon Gedanken wie können eigentlich
zwei Länder die miteinander im Konflikt
stehen diese Konflikte auch lösen das
ist ein Teil dessen was natürlich ähm
meiner Teil meines wissenschaftlichen
Interesses ist ja ja ich will deswegen
gerne mal die ganze Situation wie wir
sie haben gar nicht man aktuellen Dingen
in Bach Mut aufziehen sondern ich würde
sagen mal vom Ende her denken und dir
zum nächsten mal die Frage stellen kann
Russland diesen Krieg überhaupt auf dem
Schlachtfeld gewinnen die Frage ist was
wir unter gewinnen verstehen
[Musik]
die Russen haben ja ihre Ziele reduziert
also seit dem
22.12 letzten Jahres hat gesagt die
Parole ausgegeben volle Konzentration
auf unserem was so was das bedeutet
sozusagen wenn die Russen dieses Ziel
erreicht haben wissen wir nicht kann
sein dass das dann ausgeweitet wird ja
aber das ist momentan
das russische primäre Ziel das sehen wir
auch sozusagen in im Kriegsverlauf die
Konzentration liegt auf dem Donbass
darf dazu sollte diese berühmte
Offensive der Russen dienen die meines
Erachtens grosso modo gescheitert ist
aber wir dürfen nicht verkennen ja sie
kommen im Don was für voran ist wieso
eine Schnecke also für die für das
Material und die Anzahl von Menschen die
sie dort einsetzen kommen sie extrem
langsam voran aber sie kommen voran und
wenn das sozusagen momentan aus einer
russischen Perspektive das militärische
Ziel ist da muss man sagen dem nähern
sie sich extrem langsam aber sie nähern
sich den momentan so wenn es darüber
hinausgehende Ziele noch geben sollte da
muss man sagen dieser Krieg ist verloren
ich würde auch generell sagen russland
hat diesen Krieg eigentlich schon
verloren würdest du so sagen ja würde
ich so sagen russland hat diesen Krieg
eigentlich schon verloren weil all das
was eigentlich Kriegsgründe waren und
Kriegsziele waren hat Russland nicht
erreicht sie haben die ganzen Verlauf
ihre Kriegsziele immer weiter
runtergeschraubt natürlich in den
öffentlichen Verlautbarungen jetzt
wieder Außenminister der redet noch
immer wenn ich stellvertretende
Außenminister der redet noch immer von
den artifizierung und so weiter und so
fort aber wenn man sich anguckt was die
russischen Streitkräfte dort machen dann
ist es Positionen halten und im Dornen
was versuchen voranzukommen und wenn du
sagst russland hat den Krieg quasi schon
verloren ist aber gleichbedeutend die
andere Aussage die Ukraine hat den
deswegen nicht gewonnen genau das ist
der andere Punkt also die Ukraine hat
ihn noch lange nicht gewonnen das muss
man ganz klar sagen so und das ist halt
ähm momentan sehr verkackte Situation
für wie groß hältst du die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass im Falle sagen
wir mal ukrainischer Gewinne mit neuen
Waffen man hört ja jetzt im Moment quasi
täglich das neue Waffen wieder
eintreffen und auch langsam eingesetzt
werden wie groß ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit aus deiner Sicht wenn
Sie Erfolg haben damit das Putin nicht
dann auch davor haben wir Sorge
stationiert Atomwaffen in Belarus wie
können wir sicher sein dass er quasi
nicht eskaliert also erstens können wir
überhaupt nicht sicher sein dass er
nicht eskaliert vor allen Dingen wenn er
verliert weiter ja ich halte dennoch
sozusagen die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
Nuklearwaffen eingesetzt werden für sehr
gering
weil die Frage ist was will man mit dem
Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen erzielen also
das ist ja das ist ja die zentrale Frage
wo zu welchem Zweck würde er
Nuklearwaffen einsetzen
und wir reden ja über zwei Arten wir
reden ja sozusagen über die
fragestrategische Nuklearwaffen und die
sogenannten taktischen Nuklearwaffen ne
also den einsatzstrategischer
Nuklearwaffen das heißt man schraubt
irgendwie man schickt Raketen nach
Berlin Paris London oder sogar nach
Washington das halte ich für komplett
ausgeschlossen weil das würde letzten
Endes bedeuten Putin stimmt seine eigene
Vernichtung zu so er hat von den
Amerikanern sehr klare Signale bekommen
das sozusagen wenn er Nuklearwaffen
einsetzen würde das katastrophale
Konsequenzen für Russland haben würde
strategische Nuklearwaffen halt ich für
ausgeschlossen bleiben diese sogenannten
taktischen Nuklearwaffen übrig und dann
muss man sich die Frage stellen was will
er denn damit letzten Endes
strategischer erreichen
will er die die Ukraine unterstützenden
Staaten abschrecken weitere Waffen zu
liefern da muss man sagen der Zug ist
doch schon längst abgefahren also
letzten Endes ist doch schon alles
geliefert worden was NATO-Staaten an die
Ukraine liefern können
jetzt liefern die Polen noch die die
Mick jetzt kann man darüber reden okay
dann wird noch mal keine F16 geliefert
aber letzten Endes ist es doch so wovon
soll er denn äh die NATO-Staaten
abschrecken ja wir könnten noch
Kampfjets liefern
ist so ein riesen Blödsinn nein das muss
man ganz einfach sehen also ein ein
Deutscher u-bootkommandant und das ist
nicht der einzige Experte auf so einem
U-Boot ja der durchläuft eine
fünfjährige Ausbildung bevor er das
Patent bekommt und diese anderen
Experten durchlaufen eine ebenso lange
Ausbildung selbst wenn man die verkürzen
würde was ich schon für gefährlich
halten würde bei so einem U-Boot weil
das ist nun mal ein schwimmender sagt
Entschuldigung wenn man das so sagt wenn
man einen Fehler macht dann kann da halt
nicht sozusagen mit dem Schleudersitz
raus sondern dann ist man tot
dann reden wir noch mal von zwei Jahren
so also wir müssen die Ukrainer zwei
Jahre ausbilden weil die haben zwar
natürlich U-Bootfahrer aber das ist die
alte Kilo-Klasse das was wir haben ist
was ganz anderes dann stellt sich
nochmal die Frage kommen die Dinger
durch schwarze Meer also lässt die
Türkei die durch dann gibt es also zwei
Modelle sozusagen mit einer ukrainischen
Flagge ist das sozusagen eine
Kriegspartei lässt die Türkei die durch
mit einer deutschen Flagge müssen die
nach 21 Tagen wieder zurück sein ich
halte das für völlig bescheuert diese
der Glaube wir würden U-Boote liefern
das kannst du vom Tisch räumen das
passiert nicht also reden über
Kampfflugzeuge und wir reden noch über
attack MS also diese Kurzstreckenraketen
mit 300 km Reichweite das ist letzten
Endes das was noch fehlt in der Ukraine
würde Putin deshalb taktische
Nuklearwaffen einsetzen nein würde nicht
machen es bringt dem Nichts warum stellt
er die dann jetzt noch Weißrussland
Droge werden
Heckel sitzt hier ein Publikum wie ich
sehe der kennt sich ja solchen Sachen
viel besser aus als ich es ist ja ein
Teil dieses ganzen nuklearen Spiels also
er versucht natürlich immer diese
nuklear Drohungen abzuhalten um uns
Angst einzujagen so dass wir uns letzten
Endes selber abschrecken bestimmte
Handlungen zu unternehmen würde er
Nuklearwaffen einsetzen um die Ukraine
zu stoppen ja das kann man sich durchaus
vorstellen aber auch dann müsst der
Konsequenzen befürchten und das zweite
ist ich glaube die Ukrainer würden sich
davon nicht abschrecken lassen also es
fehlt sämtlicher wirklich strategischer
sind Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen und man
darf sich das ja nicht so vorstellen
dass der Einsatz einer Nuklearwaffe das
Kriegsgeschehen also wirklich
militärisch extrem verändern würde man
kann bei Colin Paul nachlesen der im
Zuge des ähm Golfkrieges also das 91
Krieges mal hat ausplanen lassen wie
viele taktische Nuklearwaffen die USA
eigentlich einsetzen müssen um ich
glaube den Vormarsch einer irakischen
Division ich glaube spannende Division
zu stoppen und seine Planer kamen auf so
eine hohe Anzahl das Paul gesagt hat
dass es verrückt das machen wir nicht
also darüber denken wir erst gar nicht
nach so und wenn Putin so eine hohe
Anzahl einsetzen würde müsste er mit
katastrophalen Konsequenzen gegen die
Russische Föderation rechnen also es ist
nicht auszuschließen aber es bedürfte
dann wirklich eines kompletten
verrückten Putins um das zu tun und mein
Punkt ist verrückt ist Putin nicht putin
ist in allem was er bisher getan hat ein
extrem rationaler Akteur und
Rationalität heißt nicht dass man die
richtigen Entscheidungen trifft aber man
trifft nachvollziehbare Entscheidung und
Putin ist kein Irrer
wir dürfen gerne weiterleiten
ich erinnere mich an Podcast meines
Kollegen Simon Strauß weiß auch nicht
aber hier ist ganz kurz nach
Kriegsbeginn der Titel lautete damals
wenn Putin fällt fällt die ganze Welt
oder reiste die ganze Welt mit sinngemäß
übrigens die meisten ähm gehört der
Episode die wir je produziert haben mit
ich glaube 130 000 hören nach 13 Monaten
Krieg nun die Frage wäre es eigentlich
ohne Putin wie auch immer das geschehen
sollte während es besser oder schlechter
für diese Situation
ich bin kein russlandsexperte deswegen
ist das schwer einzuschätzen aber ich
sag mal so nachdem was was mir Russland
ExpertInnen erzählen von denen ich
glaube dass sie sich wirklich gut
auskennen und auch die haben nur
begrenzte Informationen über diese
innere Dynamik und Putin herum ich sag
mal ist das beste worauf man hoffen
könnte eine Situation das Putin gestürzt
wird aus einem innersten Kreis heraus
wir jemanden bekommen der letzten Endes
die gleiche Agenda verfolgt aber der
sozusagen aus Gründen einer
strategischen oder taktischen Pause ganz
einfach so 1917 Moment also als die
deutsche Wiki die Macht erlangt haben
sind sie aus dem ersten Weltkrieg
ausgetreten sozusagen so einen Moment
herbeiführt aber solange in diesem Kreis
eine Neo imperiale Vorstellung
vorherrscht über sozusagen das was
Russland zu sein hat und wie Russland
auszusehen hat werden wir mit dieser
Gefahr einer militäre des Versuchs mit
militärischen Mitteln diese Nähe
imperiale Agenda zu verfolgen auch
weiterhin leben müssen mir
erzählen halt die ExpertInnen dass die
Vorstellung das ist dort ein kompletten
regime change von innen herausgeben
würde dass sie komplett illusorisch ist
also deshalb glaube ich ist das wäre das
Optimum dessen was wir erwarten könnten
aber es sieht momentan ja nicht danach
aus
kleiner Sprung mal über den Atlantik
auch mit Blick auf die Zeit wir haben
glaube ich nur noch 17 Minuten gekommen
auch noch zu ihnen sie dürfen auch noch
Fragen stellen wie würde denn ein
Amerika ohne beiden sagen wir mit Trump
sich in diesem Konfliktverhalten ist ja
gar nicht unmöglich dass wir in einem
guten Jahr oder in anderthalb Jahren
auch in so eine Situation wiederkommen
Trump Präsident gewesen wäre am 24.02
ähm dann hätte die Russische Föderation
komplett freie Hand in der Ukraine
mittlerweile sozusagen Moldawien auch
von russischen Truppen komplett besetzt
worden wäre und dann würden je nachdem
man dann hätten wir keine Waffen dann
hätten wir keine Waffen geliefert
zumindest nicht die Amerikaner die den
Hauptanteil anwaffen liefern
und dann würde würde die russische Armee
vor den vom Baltikum hocken ob sie das
Baltikum dann angreifen würde oder nicht
steht auf einem anderen Blatt
letzten Endes ist der Punkt wenn diese
Trump Republikaner die nächsten
Präsidentschaftswahlen gewinnen würden
dann glaube ich müssen wir uns hier in
Europa extrem warm anziehen nicht nur
mit Blick auf den Ukraine keine Konflikt
dann glaube ich sozusagen sind wir in
einer Situation in der relativ schnell
wir keine nukleare Sicherheitsgarantie
mehr seitens der Vereinigten Staaten
haben
momentan sind die Amerikaner ja in
Europa Präsident in einem Maße wie sie
glaube ich seit 2014 nicht mehr waren
dann glaube ich würden relativ schnell
die Order kommen ein Großteil dieser
Truppen zurückzuziehen
dann haben wir eine komplett neue
Situation hier in Europa auf die wir
nicht vorbereitet sind das muss man ganz
klar so sein
damit sind wir ja durchaus schon auch so
ein bisschen bei der geopolitischen
Gesamtlage wohin entwickelt sich diese
unsere Welt wann war die weltpolitische
Lage zuletzt so kompliziert und auch
Sorgen bereiten mit Blick auf Amerika
Wahlen mit Blick auf China wie in diesen
Tagen und in diesem Wochen und Monaten
ist das vergleichbar nein das ist alles
nicht vergleichbar man kann so ein paar
Punkte machen ich glaube wir also es
gibt so zwei Sachen womit ich das
historisch behalten bei aller vorsichtig
die man mit historischen analogen walten
lassen muss also ich glaube wie wir sind
in so einer Zeit wie zwischen
1947 48 bis zu 1963 das heißt nach der
Kubakrise stabilisieren wir sicher die
amerikanische sowjetischen Beziehungen
und man fängt an die ersten Abkommen zu
schließen man einigt sich auf die auf
die mad also Youtube
destruction gegenseitige zugesicherte
vernichtungsfähigkeit aber die Zeit
zwischen 47 und 63 ist halt dadurch
gekennzeichnet das sozusagen dieser
kalten dieser dieser aus westkonflikte
Krieg ausbricht
und sozusagen die die beiden großen
Mächte
ja sich gegenseitig versuchen zu ordnen
in Check zu halten mit dem Höhepunkt
Kubakrise ich glaube das kann man ganz
gut damit vergleichen weil mein Punkt
ist ja immer dass ich sage dieser
Ukraine Krieg ist ja mehr als ein Krieg
im Osten Europas der die europäische
Sicherheit nachhaltig bedroht es ist
auch der Höhepunkt momentan und
möglicherweise das ist das werden wir
die nächsten Jahre sehen es ist ein
Wendepunkt in so einem bemühen
revisionistischer Staaten
die aus ihrer Sicht gefährliche
Vorherrschaft der Vereinigten Staaten
weltweit zu brechen wo am Ende neue
Normen neue Regeln stehen Institutionen
so gestaltet sind dass sie sozusagen den
den Bedürfnissen dieser
revisionistischen Mächte eher
entsprechend
und das kann man damit durchaus
vergleichen also wir sind im Umbruch wir
sind in der Unordnung von der wenn ich
wissen wie lange sie dauern wird mit
welchen Mitteln sie noch weitergeführt
worden wird ich meine wir haben diesen
schwebenden China teil
und ich glaube ein eine der Motivationen
der Amerikaner letzten Endes dann doch
den Hebel umzudrehen man darf ja nicht
vergessen
also bis zum dezember
2021 sind ja sämtliche Staats- und
Regierungschefs der NATO der großen
NATO-Staaten nach Moskau gefahren und
haben Putin in die Hand mehr oder
weniger versprochen dass die Ukraine
niemals Mitglied der NATO werden wird
und ich glaube dass man den Hebel
umgedreht hat hat unter anderem auch
damit zu tun dass man sehr klar erkannt
hat wenn man in dieser Frage einknickt
dann liefert man für die Chinesen das
Playbook für Taiwan also muss man in
dieser Frage Einigkeit zeigen und
sozusagen in dem was entgegenhalten
damit das Signal auch in Peking
verstanden wird ob das Signal in Peking
verstanden wurde
da würde ich mal großes Fragezeichen
dahinter setzen nach der Rede von XI am
20 Parteitag der Kommunistischen Partei
aber das ist der nächste Konflikt der
sozusagen schon am Horizont genau für
welche Seite wird sich China entscheiden
in im Russland Konflikt momentan hat man
das ja das Gefühl sie nähern sich noch
sie halten sich noch alles ein bisschen
offen nein ich glaube wenn Sie sich für
einen Angriff auf Thailand entscheiden
würden dann haben wir doch das klare
Verhältnisse dann haben wir glasklare
Verhältnisse der Punkt ist sozusagen ich
glaube nicht dass die Chinesen im
Prinzip jetzt noch das nutzen werden um
jetzt Taiwan anzugreifen Chinas Rolle
ich glaube dieser Konflikt kommt China
ganz gut zu Pass weil er auf der einen
Seite die USA hier bindet ja und auch
die beiden Administration das darf man
ja nicht vergessen und das sieht man ja
auch in der National Security die ganze
ganz schön auch für die beiden
Administrationen gilt das eigentlich
volle Konzentration auf die Verhinderung
des Aufstiegs Chinas gelegt werden soll
und sie sind jetzt hier in Europa zum
Teil mit ihren Ressourcen gebunden
wenn sie weiter das werden sie nicht
mehr so lange durchhalten können
vielleicht aber aus der chinesischen
Perspektive ist das die Ablenkung die
die Chinesen haben wollen für Asien so
das ist eine den Chinesen gefällt nicht
dass der Krieg so schlecht läuft mit
Blick auf die Performance der russischen
Streitkräfte hat man auch bei der bei
der Rede von 24 Parteitag deutlich
herauslesen können
der Kotau den Putin machen musste ich
glaube bei der Shanghai Corporation
Organisation treffen gegenüber XY ist da
ja auch sehr deutlich auf der anderen
Seite
meine These egal wie dieser Konflikt
ausgeschieden aber sowieso der große
Gewinner sein entweder Russland setzt
sich durch und dann hat China sozusagen
einen erfolgreichen Juniorpartner an
seiner Seite
oder die Russen setzen sich nicht durch
in beiden Fällen sozusagen wird die
russische Wirtschaft am Boden liegen und
die Chinesen werden Russland als billige
Tankstelle benutzen für ihre eigenen
Bedürfnisse also von daher glaube ich so
oder so wird China vom Ausgang dieses
Krieges profitieren
mit dem Blick auf die Wahl in Amerika
mit dem Blick darauf was du jetzt über
China und Russland sagst klingt es doch
eigentlich nach einer guten Idee wenn
wir Europäer uns militärisch langsam
aber vielleicht doch gar nicht ganz so
langsam unabhängiger machen würden oder
können wir uns da weiter auf den auf die
NATO verlassen ich würde das nicht
unabhängiger nennen ich würde das
sozusagen ich würde sagen wir sollten
besser werden in der europäischen
Zusammenarbeit so egal wie es ausgehen
wird also selbst die Demokraten selbst
wenn die Demokraten die nächste Wahl
gewinnen würden werden Sie genau das
Einfordern ja Nation Security europa
muss mehr Verantwortung übernehmen die
Arbeitsteilung wird sein wir tragen die
Hauptlast das ist die amerikanische Idee
wir werden die Hauptlast tragen bei dem
Versuch sozusagen den russischen Neo
Imperialismus abzuschrecken und
einzudämmen wenn die Amerikaner sich auf
Asien konzentrieren und dann müssen wir
ganz einfach in der europäischen
Kooperation der Streitkräfte besser
werden und da haben wir letzten Endes ja
seit dem Amtsantritt bei beiden wo klar
war wo die Reise auch mit beiden
hingehen wird da haben wir ganz einfach
Zeit verschlafen
vielleicht ist jetzt ein guter Moment um
sie im Publikum mal mit einzubinden ich
sende mich gerade wir haben nur noch
knapp zehn Minuten und ich hätte
vielleicht auch noch zwei drei Fragen
gleich die dann auch auf den nächsten
Gast so ein bisschen abzielen der
vielleicht gleich genau auf deinem Platz
sitzt der Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
bleibt am besten sitzen und behalten
ihren Platz ich würde jetzt mal sagen es
ist ein Moment wo wir mal jemand mit dem
Mikro rumläuft ich kann das jetzt
schlecht einschätzen wer zuerst war
vielleicht einfach die nächste Person
nehmen einmal kurz vorstellen mit Namen
sehr gerne und ihre Frage dann an Carlo
Marsala
Schmidt ehemals Auswärtiges Amt könnten
Sie vielleicht einmal kurz skizzieren
sie sagten wir sollen mir müssten
demnächst enger zusammenarbeiten den
Polen Faktor und dann Deutschland
Frankreich da gibt's ja gewisse
Diskussionen
ja gerne
Polen wird ja betrachtet aufgrund seiner
Nähe zu den USA als prädestiniert
sieht sich selbst als präzisiert an eine
entscheidende Rolle zu spielen 300.000
und raketenstationiert und
ich glaube
generell dass wenn dieser Konflikt
vorbei sein wird sich auch in der
innereuropäischen machbalance vieles
verändern wird und ich sage immer wenn
Deutschland und Frankreich glauben sie
können dann zurück zum daily business
gehen das heißt diese
deutsch-französische Achse die wenn sie
übereinstimmt den Rest irgendwie
mitzieht dann wird sowohl Berlin als
auch Paris mit klammersack gepudert sein
das machen die Polen nicht mehr mit das
machen die beiden nicht mehr mit sondern
man muss die also man muss die innere
europäische macht Balance sozusagen neu
ordnen ob das jetzt im Rahmen des Weimar
Dreiecks ist oder andere Formate das sei
jetzt mal dahingestellt aber man muss
ganz einfach akzeptieren dass Mittel und
Osteuropa nicht mehr so
nachrangig behandelt werden kann wie man
das die letzten 20 25 Jahre gemacht hat
das werden die nicht mehr mit sich
machen lassen die Polen tun alles dafür
und jetzt kommt natürlich beim bei Polen
vor allen Dingen mit der mit der
jetzigen Regierung immer noch so ein
antideutscher Zug dabei die Polen tun
alles dafür um der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland militärisch dann den Rang
als wichtigster nicht konventioneller
macht in der NATO abzulaufen und sie
sind dabei auf einen guten Weg das muss
man ganz einfach auch so sagen also hier
müssen die Karten neu verhandelt werden
nur dann wird es funktionieren und
deshalb sage ich auch wir müssen wir
Europäer müssen besser werden jeder
versucht diese also die die verbesserte
europäische Kooperation unter einem
Souveränität und Autonomie Label zu
framen der möglicherweise darauf abzielt
auch wenn es nur rhetorisch ist die NATO
zu untergraben wird keine Zustimmung im
Mittel und aus Europa und den Baltikum
finden deswegen sage ich wir müssen
besser werden und gleichzeitig weiterhin
sozusagen in der NATO sein mit der NATO
kooperieren und auch besser in der NATO
werden nur so macht es Sinn wenn die
NATO dann auseinander fliegt dann haben
wir die Strukturen um es möglicherweise
europäisch zu machen aber wir sollten
das nicht mit dem Label wie es in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten immer der Fall
war sozusagen der Autonomie Europas weil
darum geht es Hauptsächlich autonomen
von wem von den USA zu werden Labeln
weil das werden die Mittel und
Osteuropäer nicht nach nicht mitmachen
danke schön weitere Fragen vielleicht
Johannes Jakob Herr Professor Masala
vielen lieben Dank ich hätte eine Frage
ich habe jetzt einen Sohn der etwa
anderthalb Jahre alt ist und mit Blick
darauf das jetzt eine
un-sicherheitsratsmitglied die un-karte
gebrochen hat die Genfer Konvention
fortlaufend bricht was bedeutet das
eigentlich für die sicherheitsordnung
die jetzt mein Sohn hineingeboren wird
und welche möglichen Wege gibt es
vielleicht mit Blick auf die
Nachkriegsperiode die Sie angesprochen
haben um wieder zu einer stabileren
sicherheitsordnung weltweit zu kommen
also zunächst einmal muss man ja sagen
dass die Russische Föderation nicht das
erste Mitglied des Sicherheitsrates der
Vereinten Nationen ist das Völkerrecht
bricht ja
das zweite ist es herrscht ja in der
Bundesrepublik ich betone jetzt wirklich
in der Bundesrepublik woanders ist das
auch der Fall es herrscht eine
eigentümliche Vorstellung vor über die
Funktion diese Sicherheitsrates weil
wenn Sie sich anschauen als der
Sicherheitsrat damals im Prinzip
gegründet und erfunden wurde die
ursprüngliche Konzeption meine vor
policeman Konzeption also die war
sozusagen die die wichtigsten Staaten
der Anti Hitler Allianz bestimmen die
Geschichte der Welt für die Zukunft das
fand dann keine so große Zustimmung bei
anderen Staaten also wurde der
Sicherheitsrat erweitern aber das
Prinzip war immer das gleiche der kann
nur funktionieren wenn seine ständigen
Mitglieder übereinstimmen Interessen
haben wenn sie die nicht haben gibt es
legitimerweise das vetorrecht so und
jetzt sind sie ich sag das jetzt einfach
mal ist ein Kompliment ansehen jetzt
sind sie sicherlich in der Zeit
aufgewachsen sozusagen die nach dem
auswest-konflikt war wo man geglaubt hat
sozusagen eine Sicherheitsrat ist jetzt
das zentrale Instrument weil dieser
Block Gegensatz nicht mehr da ist und
man jetzt feststellt der Sicherheitsrat
funktioniert genauso wie er eigentlich
seit 1945 immer funktioniert hat bis
1990 hat einer ein anderes Interesse
liegt das ein Veto ein und dann
funktioniert das funktioniert ja nicht
also diese ganzen Hoffnungen auf die UN
die hielt ich ja immer für übertrieben
so funktioniert internationale Politik
nicht hier Sohn wird vielleicht wenn er
18 oder 20 ist in einer neuen
Bipolarität Leben so und zwar in einer
chinesische amerikanischen Bipolarität
ähm die durch Konkurrenz und Kooperation
gekennzeichnet sein wird das
grundlegende Problem glaube ich dass wir
haben die letzten 30 Jahre ist jede jede
internationale Ordnung die sozusagen auf
auf stabiler Polarität beruht weil sie
bipolar oder sei sie multipolar ist ein
Wechselspiel zwischen Konkurrenz und
Kooperationsverhältnis
also selbst die Sowjetunion und die
Amerikaner die sich in vielen Gegenden
dieser Welt als Erzfeinde begegneten
hatten dennoch gemeinsam Interessen die
sie konsequent verfolgt haben also dass
wir diese ganze nicht Proliferation dass
wir das Ganze lichtpoliferationsregime
zum Beispiel haben ist ja ein ein
Ausfluss aus dem Interesse beider Seiten
dass die Verbreitung von Nuklearwaffen
weder im Interesse der USA noch der
serverunion war dass wir sowas wie
unpieß keeping haben was in der Karte
der Vereinten Nation gar nicht
vorgesehen ist ist ein Ausfluss aus dem
gemeinsamen Interesse der Sowjetunion
und der USA regionale Konflikte wo sie
beide sehr stark involviert waren also
durch Unterstützung jeweils der ein oder
anderen Partei nicht so weit Ausatmen zu
lassen dass sie gezwungen gewesen wären
aktiv einzugreifen weil das hätte
bedeuten die andere Seite wäre auch
aktiv reingegangen und man hätte wieder
sozusagen dieses Damokles Schwert des
dritten Weltkrieges gehabt also von
daher stabile Polarität schafft auch
eine gewisse Ordnung ob die einem
gefällt oder nicht sei dahingestellt
normativ gesehen
aber vielleicht wenn ihr Sohn erwachsen
ist wird er in einer Bipolarität
aufwachsen
so du gibst immer so lange Antwort jedem
einzelnen dass die Zeit jetzt schon fast
komplett rum ist ich würde sagen
vielleicht schaffen wenn ich nur JA oder
NEIN Frage eine Frage schaffen wir noch
und du musst dann aber kürzer Antworten
okay
dann versuche ich jetzt kurz zu machen
Jens Lemke meine Name die Sprachen von
der medialen Präsenz und äh ich habe
beobachtet nach dem Krieg tauchten
häufig im ZDF vier Sterne generell auf
aber ja ich weiß und ich habe vor sechs
sieben Jahren mal das Glück gehabt deine
eigenen Veranstaltung an der Vorgänger
in general Hansen über seine Sicht auf
die Welt war zu hören mir fiel auf das
sind ja hochgebildete kriegshandwerke
also schlimmen an das Wort über Lippen
geht ich habe nicht wahrgenommen dass
die Politik auf diese Fachleute gehört
hat nehmen Sie das heute anders war wie
wie schätzen Sie das eigentlich
unterstelle das auch sie in der Politik
gehört werden die Frage ist worauf
sollten Sie denn hören worauf sollte die
Politik hören Entschuldigung jetzt aber
da muss ja gut also das damals war das
Thema Abrüstung keine Nachlieferung
keine Bevorratung von Munition Hansen
berichtete ich habe mein Logistiker
kommt wann kommen die nächste Munition
nicht abgeben musste für Afghanistan 5
Jahre später
diese Themen also wirklich ganz sachlich
wenn Sie wollen ingenieurmäßig mal durch
die trainiert wenn wir
verteidigungsfähig wenn ich B haben will
muss ich ja machen und wir machen aber
nicht ja das ich sag jetzt mal folgendes
einige von denen werden schon gehört und
sind sozusagen während beratend
hinzugezogen das Problem letzten Endes
ist immer eine politische Entscheidung
so und wenn Sie ein ehemaligen
generalfragen ja der wird immer Lösungen
vorschlagen die gut sind aber teuer sind
und wenn die Politik dafür kein Geld
ausgeben wird wird das nicht machen das
ist ja das generelle Problem von
Beratung ohnehin ja also das heißt wir
werden gehört aber es heißt ja nicht
unbedingt dass man uns folgt
schöner Übergang zu machen
schöner Übergang zur letzten Frage du
kommst nicht drumrum hier zu unserem
nächsten Gast noch ein Wort zu sagen zu
deutschen Figur die wir in diesem du
guckst ganz erschrocken auf die Zeit ne
du hast gleich nicht mehr viel
Scholz Annalena baerbock und der Ampel
in dieser Situation in guten Händen
kurze Antwort diese Regierung befindet
sich in einer Situation in der sich nie
einer Regierung befunden hat sozusagen
sie muss in Kriegszeiten Unterstützung
leisten in einer Situation die allen
unklar ist es gibt nichts worauf man da
sozusagen zurückgreifen kann und wo man
sagen kann das war schon mal so das
haben wir so gemacht das war erfolgreich
wir machens also ein bisschen ist das ja
auch irgendwie auf Sicht fahren dafür
machen sie es wirklich nicht schlecht
danke schön
danke dir vielmals